antoine bonjour alors dans le cadre de
la lutte contre le virus le parlement
russe se réunir aujourd'hui afin entre
autres de donner des prérogatives plus
importante au gouvernement où en sont
ces travaux parlementaires mais bien la
douma d'ores et déjà de thé ce matin en
première lecture un projet de loi
permettant d'accorder au gouvernement
des pouvoirs supplémentaires donc dans
le cadre de la crise sanitaire en cours
des pouvoirs supplémentaires comme le
droit d'introduire des mesures
exceptionnelles en cas d'urgence sur
l'ensemble du territoire ou bien sur une
zone délimitée
le gouvernement est également autorisés
à restreindre le commerce de certains
appareils médicaux en particulier ceux
considérés comme indispensables dans la
lutte contre la pandémie de kobe 19 tout
un système d'amendés a également été
adopté par la chambre basse du parlement
en deuxième lecture d un vent qui
commence à partir de 15 mille roubles
soit à peu près 170 euros en cas de
violation du régime de quarantaine des
amendes importantes sont également
prévues pour ceux qui font circuler de
fausses informations sur le corps d'un
virus à noter également que les mesures
de confinement s'étendent à travers le
pays après moscou
c'est saint pétersbourg qui vient
d'adopter des mesures similaires en
russie se sont janvier 2003 137
personnes qui sont contaminées pour 17
morts selon les chiffres officiels
et malgré tout les autorités continuent
de venir en aide aux pays les plus
touchés
après les avions en voyant l'italie un
premier appareil remplis de matériel
médical a été envoyé aux états unis
merci beaucoup antoine gayraud pour
toutes ces précisions en direct de
moscou